Comcast are you kidding me with these 62
seconds of logos this bad mom's age of
Ultron or some boy I'm ami Mitchell and
I'm a mom farm splaining also narration
damn can't this movie squeeze in some
reading to give us the trifecta right at
the beginning then I shuttle the kids to
piano lessons and soccer games and dance
classes and doctor's appointments before
my daily trip to the grocery store daily
listen if Amy's life is this being full
of errands can't she plan ahead and get
some extra supplies I mean there are no
Costco's in the city baby here's your
project they made you what kind of
project is that exactly it's just a big
head of Richard Nixon make a battlefield
and stick some toy soldiers in there to
signify whatever war you want it to be
also come on I know she's actually a
great mom but she's not a professional
sculptor right so how'd she make this
incredibly realistic bust of Nixon kids
acting embarrassed about moms affection
in a public place cliche I don't know
how you do it you just leave your kids
all day and go to work yeah but the
asshole moms are also leaving their kids
all day too right unless they work at
the school and that too would make this
contradictory if you're gonna use some
intimidating tactics to make me feel bad
use some semblance of logic lady is this
your way of saying that you want to
start selling your coffee to hotels now
this is my way of saying that I want you
to start selling our coffee to hotels
now main characters boss is a douche
that puts upon their grudgingly willing
subordinate cliche you know I'm just
part-time
no oh I know but I have a family and
stuff I know most of this is to show how
hard Amy's working compared to these
millennial asshats that don't do
anything but why the would she be
part-time she's there every day this is
just basic business math also I thought
she was already running sales for
supermarkets airlines and restaurants so
how the hell is the term part-time even
possible how was work
oh I had two conference calls and I took
a nap it was exhausting Jesus Christ we
get it Amy's family is being awful can
we just get to the part where she starts
boozing and in slow-mo did you hear
Dylan get a D on his science quiz
we go bud this scene is essentially what
you'd see at the ninth City improv
troupe during their Tuesday night show
in downtown Naperville coach is posting
a list of
made the team tonight at 9:00 I'm
freaking out on an arbitrary and late
time to post something like this what
happened to the days of just posting a
printed list outside the cafeteria so
everyone could gather in a big group and
shun the losers who didn't make the cut
together do you understand how hard it
is to get into an Ivy League school now
I mean they turn away Asians that's
right it's a little racist damn it Amy I
know you're good at everything but leave
us sitting to meet yeah I was
masturbating online with some sherry why
are you doing that and why the hell
didn't Mike lock the door how long have
you been doing this oh I don't know not
long I get that she stays on for comedic
exposition but why the fuck didn't Mike
keep trying to close the browser window
or at the very least turn off the
monitor also Amy's gone all day and
apparently Mike generally works from
home so couldn't he do this then my
point is that this jerk-off has some
stupid jerk-off habits so much try to do
everything myself
sit hey how's n't the first 10 minutes
of this movie bit about how amy has to
do everything by herself every day okay
a little weird stay-at-home mom these
were just making fun of Amy for working
so aren't they also stay-at-home moms
damn it I'm sick of these arbitrary
insults here comes the hot widower and
for a supposedly subversive comedy this
movie is piling on the conclusion let's
add the hot guy first appears while
walking in slow motion 1 2 the heat
gwendolyn's been at the same spot
handing out flyers all morning but
specifically knocks on Amy's window in
order to further prove her asshole
titude this girl didn't see that
someone's now standing in her path wait
I realized that Amy quit the PTA but
where the hell are kids right now
did you put being a mom I guess it well
they're old enough to stay by themselves
for a while but now not long enough for
her to kill several bottles of scotch
have you trained Kiki granted I'm not a
super hot woman but I have boosted up
enough to know that it's not standard
practice for the bartender to bring out
the whole bottle when you order one
drink having a quiet breakfast by myself
yes Carla so jazzed about by all
accounts including her own she's a
terrible mom who pretty much does
whatever she wants screw it let's be bad
moms roll credits also one of the many
problems with this movie is that they
had to include this line which is
completely unnecessary to get the point
across the hangover didn't have a moment
when Bradley Cooper looked at the other
two and said you know what I have the
hangover
Amy's jacket still has a bit of
spaghetti stain but her
white shirt has become a reckons Lee
spot-free this is really more of a
choking hazard than it is bad mom
behavior and yet another entry in this
movie series of cliches the protagonists
become fed up with their situation and
briefly engaged in destructive behavior
you can apparently buy an entire suit of
armor at this grocery store but even if
that's the case wouldn't this be like a
dog food bag and they would just type in
the UPC instead of trying to run it
across the scanner okay great scene and
all but they literally wasted hundreds
of dollars worth of booze alone not to
mention the cereal and the other so the
stores just gonna let that slide
shee I know Amy typically had running
smoothly in the mornings but could they
not look for her in a room or something
take your daddy's special car today
they really make it seem like Mike would
be so pissed about this but he never
mentions it and Amy drives it for the
rest of the movie
Jesus whenever Amy does something bad do
we have to see it in slow motion a sec
Snyder somehow involved in this movie
[Music]
Amy somehow stopped at an Arby's on the
way to school which was not only open
early in the morning but also happened
without the kids realizing it also those
roast beef sandwiches are gonna be
ice-cold by lunchtime
so enjoy your disgusting meal kids I
guess in addition to becoming bad moms
these three also decided to become just
generally terrible human beings when I
was in my 20s I would just walk down the
street and it would just it would just
be raining ducks but this performance
the role of rebel Wilson will be played
by Kathryn Hahn
who's watching the kids Rosie isn't it
your job
Keke's asshole husband shows up to
asshole for two seconds in the scene
only to set up a two second resolution
later in the movie I love these things
I'm enjoy that she's adorable
thank you you can tell this is a good
father because he's hot and he's holding
his daughter's hand but yet he refuses
to even offer her a donut hole weird
outbursts in there terrible style this
is yet another scene to make Wendelin
look like a bitch but isn't Amy kind of
in the wrong here to be slinging a
single box of store-bought donut holes
and furthermore why she even at the bake
sale I thought she quit this I get that
Carla snuck them into the spa but they
would still have to have an appointment
for all they're doing no because I'm
your mom I know what you're made of did
anyone tell me like who knows that this
was a raunchy thoughtless comedy that
didn't require this level of acting I
mean she didn't even try this already
Jupiter ascending
you know I can't discuss specific
players with you and you know that I
chair the hiring and firing committee
right how the hell is this a thing I
know very little about the power of PTA
presidents but if it's this then that's
dumb I want to get laid and it should be
impossible for a woman that looks like
Mila Kunis to accomplish this without
external help it's my favorite are you
trying to get laid or adopted this
movie's just a series of failed sketches
that wouldn't have made it past dress
rehearsal at SNL and have you seen the
SNL that's on the air these days hold on
this was like my slutty Halloween
costume from college but the costume is
this other than a black dress man I
guess it's a good thing Amy kept this
outfit all this time and that she's the
exact same size she was in college oh
look at your mom bra we're 36 minutes in
we've already had at least 36 comments
about how unsexy amy is
now we have to deal with this scene
where she has nothing sexy enough to
wear so she can get laid when in reality
she could wear her work outfit from
earlier with the coffee and spaghetti
spilled all over it and she would still
have to turn guys away you'd make three
regular bras out of this one mom Brock
the director said maybe if we say the
word bra enough times people will take
the cue to laugh right
no of course this wasn't just a cheap
excuse to have Mila Kunis take her shirt
off Kenzie's never heard this it's up to
Street minutes of pure unadulterated top
look I'm sure women talk graphically
about penises all the time and how to
work them and while doing their makeup
in the hopes of getting their friend
late but wait I lost my train of thought
I guess I need to watch this scene again
hang on Carla and Kiki were just bagging
on Amy's wardrobe for being terrible but
not only did they raid her closet for
their outfits tonight Amy just happens
to be the exact size as both of them
really feels like the police should be
alerted to these threes criminal
behavior as soon as they see the slow
motion appear also apparently Amy's kids
are being yet again looked after tonight
if she had such a bang-up babysit her
support system all this time why was she
so stressed out
hey driving an uber is not considered
consent how are you I would start with
maybe like just got fat and Jewish so
the opposite of Mel Gibson I like your
wedding ring
I was grocery shopping and I found it on
the floor and I picked it up and and
then I put it on I'm gonna sit somewhere
else okay I know we're flipping the
script on the typical raunchy comedy but
do we need to completely ignore typical
male behavior
Amy could be wearing her wedding dress
sitting next to her husband and his
family have two kids attached to her in
slings and guys would still hit on her
especially if she's the one instigating
Kim kind of always had a thing for you
you knew that why why would she know
that as far as we can tell they've met
once at a bake sale you take your kids
to all those activities and you do all
those insane projects seriously how does
he know all these things take out the
comedic overtones and this could be a
creepy stalker Lifetime movie I saw your
Richard Nixon by the way that was
incredible dude pump the brakes I know
this is going well but it's probably a
little early to start talking about
paper mache sculptures of disgraced
former political figures movie cruelly
Skip's Amy's inevitable sexting that
followed Jessie's message also did they
have sex or what wasn't the whole point
of the night to get her laid I mean
movie spent a lot of time setting that
whoa there shouldn't Amy be doing this
in slow motion all I want to do is make
enough money to feed my cats and filmic
impress
this joke presupposes that Jay
J want whatever fit into a Prius how
dare you bench my daughter you have no
right to do that actually I do because
soccer is a PTA sponsored activity and I
am the president of the PTA really
because when you were trying to get JJ
to do what you wanted you used your
hiring and firing committee leverage
instead of using the power position that
made the most sense well yeah
Jada pinkett-smith has heard this line
so much from her husband she just
instinctively adds it to all of her
performances Gwendolen has been
president of the PTA for the last six
years let's assume that a PTA board
would even let someone be president for
six terms and that Gwendolyn spaced her
kids out to cover that period of time in
middle school where the hell are her
kids that they're never shown in this
movie she's got the attachment mom she's
got the tiger mom's the the sad mom she
has the blogging moms this goes on for
some time how convenient for him either
her feud with Gwendolyn happened right
as they were about to elect a new PTA
president would this make more sense at
the beginning or end of the school year
my kid eats butter like an entree my
daughter stole money from a homeless
woman he's escalating my kid did this
anecdotes are like a bag of Doritos
they're perfectly adequate to pass the
time but there's no goddamn substance so
where are your kids tonight out they're
staying at a friend's house I guess that
friend's mom isn't allowed to be bad
since she's likely been taking care of
Amy's kids for the last several days
okay first off it's Amy the other two
had all these moms cell numbers why
didn't she do a mass text instead of
handing out flyers for the campaign also
everyone was on their best behavior
during the presentation for fear of
reprisal from Gwendolyn but one drunken
picture inviting them to a booze party
was enough to create an entire mutiny in
the middle of that presentation would
you ladies like a jello shot ah that's
funny
but how did she make these just now at
Amy's house homemade jello takes at
least three hours to set so even though
Martha Stewart is magic those are some
bullsh jello shots
I swear to god I'm not slowing these
clips down it happens every fucking time
they act up I think that we as moms do
way too much stuff Amy who's been shown
raging on the booze for hours now
suddenly become sober enough to make an
intelligible speech for her candidacy I
actually may have did you off my phone
oh because what she wrote was disturbing
but you still showed up right so either
you're into some disturbing shit and
you're playing it off like you're not or
you're down for whatever as long as you
can get your wet is she seriously going
to counseling after having sex with
Jessie you the night before I mean I'm
all for saving a marriage but maybe give
a three-day buffer after you cheat on
your spouse
I like your spaghetti and you make
pretty good calzone was that three I
realized that we need to hate Amy's
husband so we can respect her finding
the perfect man somewhere else or
whatever this movie is shoving down our
throats but I'm pretty sure the fact
that he's been cheating on her for the
last 10 months was enough things like
this are just piling it on and they're
not even funny more interesting I think
you should get divorced this is
catastrophic okay this is played for
laughs but Jesus what a terrible
therapist
nobody was accused of criminal behavior
or abuse or any bullshit that would be
automatic grounds for recommending
divorce
I mean it's been three minutes and they
yelled at each other once okay I guess
that chapters been tied up nice and
clean nothing more to see here let's
move on to what I'm sure will be a
hilarious final act that will feature a
comeuppance a resolution to every
problem and even more slow motion
shenanigans the initial pitch for this
movie somehow made it into the script
you are so selfish and a frigging suck
lose day with dad tonight even he's a
better parent geez is anyone in this
movie actually likable the kids are
spoiled and entitled Mike's a lazy
asshole Amy did her office space
transition without caring about the
repercussions leaving JJ Watt is kind of
a douche bag in this movie I may have
just pissed off JJ Watt hmm I love your
sex celebration dude now we just need to
pray that Amy's little crackhead
daughter kids the help she needs okay
but wouldn't it make more sense for
Gwendolyn to have frame Dillon for this
she's already with Jane by getting her
benched on a soccer team but she's a
dedicated student that's hoping for the
Ivy League at 12 years old
Dillon looks like a much more likely
suspect than Jane to have drugs in his
locker Bosco
to a day ago Mike was considered
completely unfit to look after any of
his kids especially by himself but today
he's just gonna take the entire family
as this sad song plays after a breakup
in subsequent family crisis cliche plays
out I'm reminded that I'm essentially
watching every romantic comedy ever only
with more references to blowjobs to get
prepared for the scene Mila Kunis just
had to remember that one time that
Macaulay Culkin dragged her to see his
band play an entire set about Pizza
Wendelin you have five minutes I'll talk
as long as I want can we talk for a
second about how Wendell Pierce who
plays the principal gets treated in
movies the man was on the fucking wire
he's a really good actor but he's in
this for 10 seconds playing a powerless
principal right after we last saw him in
Twilight in Breaking Dawn Part and to
all the moms in school hate me what is
Amy basing this on just a night or two
ago they were all having a great time
together and we've seen no confrontation
since then
sure Gwendolyn was talking to the two
random moms to make us think otherwise
but Amy wasn't there for that no
quitting is for dads this movie is
addictive dad yes I can't win the
election oh my god this is not about the
election it is however about following
the template of the protagonist saying
they're definitely not gonna do
something right before they do no way
you could have sit here and let
Gwendolyn get away with this
carla has a good point regardless of
Amy's transformation during this movie
she's still been supporting her kids but
she didn't do jack to protest the weed
that was found in Jane's locker even
though it clearly wasn't hers get those
tits up get him up get him up get your
boobs get those tits right up I've lost
count of the times in which these three
repeats something endlessly in the hopes
that it'll become funny after a while
but here it is again and Shelby's in
damn it jesus H Christ man
Amy's speeding to the one place that
she's been the most for the last several
years but we need this wrong way for
nonsense to add to the hilarity come on
moving just end no seriously how good
did it feel because we've been given no
information about this relationship by
than the fact that the husband made Kiki
leave lunched at one time and that he
has a limp but I guess go girl
when it comes to being a mom I have no
clue what I'm doing moms love it when
you drop a few f-bombs during your PTA
speech at the middle school ha ha ha my
kids haven't had a bath in three weeks
hey remember that game we played a while
back comparing how awful our kids are
let's do that again on a bigger scale
gotta play the hits I guess wait did she
just win all she did was
make a speech and they were like seven
people that stood up and said something
did the standing ovation just count us
an official victory the hell are the
rules here give me like a second sure
not to immediately call my children or
my newfound love interest or anything
just to check in on my campaign right
[Music]
god damn it how many can cliches are
there in this movie now we have a
sympathetic villain at the end of the
movie entry and I'm telling you I can
not take much more of this I'm sorry for
acting so crazy about the whole soccer
thing
look I know children's attitudes can
change on a dime the last time we saw
these kids everything was terrible they
even played a sad song while Mila
crunched out a single tear but now
everything's hunky-dory
I guess because Amy got elected
president of the PTA or some both at
this point I'd rather be watching slo-mo
shots of the moms looting a grocery
store the company is falling apart
without you could you please come back
Clark Duke ex machina also I guess Dale
too heard about Amy's magical PTA win
which fixes everything
oh hi love interest that's had about
three minutes of screen time I guess
it's time to again chop chop sorry I'm
gonna come to your baseball game
tomorrow night
for real I mean seriously did Amy's PTA
win also cure at bolo reversed climate
change and fix all the other wrongs in
the world has anyone checked the White
House is Biff Tannen outside putting on
a second coat of wax right now I have my
husband's plane the whole day so so now
they're hanging with gwyndolin after all
those years of hating her oh yeah she
also did that little thing which you put
weed in Jane's Locker remember that yeah
well private plane and stuff an
additional three minutes of real bad
mommy
I'm Amy Mitchell and I'm a mom this is
my neighborhood this is my street
another pervert I just was looking for
turbo man doll
I've been bruised in burns stabbed shot
poisoned frozen home electrocuted if
you're going hard enough left you'll
find yourself here and right so I just
have to kind of fool this penis up like
a balloon animal
oh I think I got pregnant is it cool
maybe I just spray a little Pam down in
that area right before the baby comes
out okay go down in you again baby
please I am NOT from huffing sometimes
I'm so crazy that I don't even
understand the words that are coming out
of my mouth do you understand the words
that are coming out of my mouth